a cinco se incrementó el número de
soldados fallecidos luego de intentar
cruzar el río ilave en puno al sur del
Perú una patrulla tenía por misión
controlar las manifestaciones del fin de
semana en la localidad de Juli donde los
protestantes contra la presidenta Dina
boluarte incendiaron una comisaría y un
tribunal de Justicia los pobladores
aimaras denunciaron que los militares
habrían sido presionados por sus
superiores para cruzar el río un grupo
de soldados fue rescatado por los
pobladores pero medios locales
difundieron vídeos donde se aprecia una
turba atacando con piedras y palos a la
patrulla militar algunos sobrevivientes
señalaron que alrededor de 300
pobladores les bloquearon el paso y al
ser atacados con piedras y palos
tuvieron que cruzar el río para
resguardar su integridad el general
Johnny León jefe de la región militar
del Sur del Perú afirmó que los
manifestantes atacaron a los soldados y
que prácticamente se trató de un
asesinato opositores al gobierno exigen
que la presidenta Dina boluarte y el
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola respondan
por la muerte de los cinco militares por
su parte el presidente del Congreso José
Williams pide una exhaustiva
investigación por parte de las
autoridades en paralelo la defensoría
del pueblo Lamento del fallecimiento de
los soldados y solicitó a la comandancia
general del ejército y al comando
unificado de puno indagar las
circunstancias en que ocurrieron los
decesos el organismo también pidió a la
fiscalía actuar conforme a sus
atribuciones para sancionar a los
responsables